[Music]
today I have the pleasure of introducing
professor Jennifer ocker
as the moderator and interviewer and
professor Jennifer aqua is the general
atlantic professor of marketing and she
is a leading expert on how purpose and
meaning shape the choices individuals
make and how money can end time can be
used in ways to cultivate long lasting
happiness and particularly appropriate
how technology can positively impact
human wellbeing and Jennifer will be in
conversation today with Eric you on the
founder and CEO of zoom so I'll turn it
over now to Jennifer Jennifer Thank You
Bryan
first of all Eric it's really a delight
to have you here I think don't tell
anyone else but we think you are the
most popular speaker and all of business
and society but I didn't say that the
students didn't say that but that's the
feeling I have thank you so much for
being here we couldn't be more excited I
wanted to start off with a personal
question so some of the students have
read that zoom was founded due to love
and that you got the idea of starting
zoom during college in China when you
were a 10 hour train ride away from your
girlfriend and you were only able to see
her twice a year and apparently thought
it'd be fantastic if there was a
technology that would solve that problem
so the question is is this true and
second how did it all work out both with
the relationship and your view on the
technology yeah first of all Jennifer
Anna brand thank you so much for your
invitation it's my great honor to join
this event and thank you so much that's
a true story and a good news my
girlfriend so she's my wife and now and
it's back to 1987 and I just became a
freshman student and I met her and
unfortunately she was in a different
College when you're older than me and in
a different City back to 1987 and 1988
if you ever had experience through ride
on a train China you will know that
horrible horrible experience I can stand
there sleep sleeping without any problem
meaning so many people are just around
me and it's not that easy there's no
direct you know trim and then it took me
almost a mounatin hours and one day I
thought about that hey in the future
maybe I have a device it's just a one
click I can talk with her I can see her
that'd be cool there's Monica daydream I
never thought about that a buting a
solution opinions in the future just for
that when we until when we had a foster
prototype you know the product a
suddeniy i could have connected dots and
that's a part of this allow the story
yeah yeah well so I think that the
lesson learned here is that we all need
to fall in love and find a technology
technology solution that will change the
world so over the last couple of months
the world is discovered zoom so to set
this stage for us can you give us a
sense of the capacity you've developed
in such a short period of time so first
just thinking about January 2020 how
many users or what was the call volume
then versus now and how much is zooms
workforce grown in that same period yeah
that's better back to LA I think lava is
indeed everything because of love you
know and when the pandemic crisis
started we I talked to our team our team
working so hard
hour ago is no matter what do all we can
at no cost to have people stay connected
so we have our own data centers and
however our capacity only reserved for
twice of the peak time capacity when
pandemic crisis started if we wouldn't
be leveraged our own data center there's
no way for us to see why the good news
costs I was part of the WebEx team you
know badly 2000 the why you know because
of 9/11 we already learn a hard lesson
you're standing you have so many users
if you will
your own data center it's really harder
to be suitable so good news from
architecture perspective we support a
public cloud meaning new Amazon Cloud
and leave home at an Oracle cloud we can
add more capacity per level to do the
public cloud infrastructure so over the
night and almost every day every night
for a while we we had to add like a five
thousand you know sometimes six thousand
servers and to all we can to scale up
our service good news we survived and at
a new cost so talk us through that how
did you manage to press on the
accelerator pedal so fiercely while
adapting to new remote work demands
where they're kind of one or two
insights of how you actually managed to
do that I think first of all you know
the one thing we got to embrace the new
reality we know you know a lot of people
they are gonna work from home right from
our perspective we need to all we can
you know to always scale up our service
to offer our tools like is right habit
it was sleek negative at the same time
is more like a you know is where open
you know it's always listened to our
customers get their feedback and quickly
change listen for our employees as long
as you think about you want to embrace
the changes right you want to be open
transparent I think every Cirrus will
fall um we related to that you know
there's stories about how how not only
were you guys born based on love but it
was really this customer service and
during the early stages of zoom you
would you would write to every customer
who cancelled your service so at what
point was that unsustainable and and
also what did you learn during those
days when you would email
individually these customers yes so
thank you for asking about that a
question so you know that is really give
me a lot of a sweeter store memories so
in early stage our service
is a monthly subscription is was wounded
999 less than $10 a month and for the
first two Sarah most every time when we
had a one pager subscribers we all know
that we are so excited today we have a
five paid a subscribers you know this is
huge fire is like well you lost what 20
percent is gone
right I feel like wow my 20% of
repeaters of us subscribers they are
going to leave our service that's why I
send it out of them a personal email
sometime replied back and I stated a
call to understand why they tell us
maybe the feature prob maybe performance
so we had to face sometimes interesting
enough they don't believe that human was
for me they even paraded me believe me I
mean you know I remember where you know
like that
zoom is not honest the company how come
your marketing focus impersonate you as
a CEO sent me this email they do not
trust what I learned in the email and
then I needed pry back I said let's have
a zoom call I mean in deal with the real
zoom see you and because of that guess
what those users became very loyal for
our service but later on I think I got a
so many he news because we have a tenth
of a thousand the paid subscribers every
day because all my subscribers
the trend is ready to go hi I if I still
do that I cannot do anything else so I
stopped yeah um moving fast often means
breaking things so first do you agree
with that question it's a very Silicon
Valley type of question and second um if
yes what do you think you broke and how
might you fix it and when I say you I
don't really mean you I mean like what
do you think you know it has broken and
how do you fix it I think I really like
that's sitting liberally man sure I
think it even today I think from day one
until today I think every day a lot of
things are stupid
this reason why ringing
harder right to keep fixing all those
problems if you sink your penis in
perfect shape something already very
wrong so have excited that our
philosophy philosophy was always as long
as we do the right thing with great
intention speed is everything meaning we
are not afraid of those problems as long
as we act quickly it's not as we focus
on speed well we are going to be okay
the reason why is your competitors we
are gonna have a similar problems as
well if you can move faster than them if
you can fix the problem when they are
well make one quarter ahead of them I
think we can so I so that's our
philosophy if your differential
advantage is speed you know good intent
and speed and what are one or two you
know sort of secret ingredients that
allow you to be so agile that allow you
to not only be that that responsive but
also quick too quick to tackle the
challenge it's good a question I think a
number one is about trust you know when
you build up a nice and you recruited a
team member or your senior executives if
is there's no trust there's no speed so
you know like I assume we we sort of
making a mandatory everyone should read
a book called speed of trust because if
a trust exists is relatively
straightforward because every day
there's full of problems even if I work
for marketing department if I see
something wrong in a six department I'd
like to talk zone and because I trust
them because of that we can fix a lot of
the issues otherwise we be hating first
of all that's fantastic
we're all gonna read that book as
zooming replaces in-person meetings
you're redefining human interaction I'm
curious about how you think zoom impacts
people's ability to connect and
communicate with each other yes
to have a people stay connected is very
important I remember that you know many
years ago quite often it's back to the
speed back to the trust I found when
thing is very interesting we have
employees while I was still at a Cisco
we have employees working remotely and
quite often I send them email or chat a
message and on a phone call I working
together with them for almost the 12 3
years it's very hard to get a trust they
still do not know who I am
I also do not know who they are right
into my soul for a relationship or all
those you know personal experience would
me and Hill with thing on video you
realized is much easier to engage with
your employees to build trust so it's
it's better to the trust relationship we
another thing I realized I really think
is really happy the productivity is how
we also did it tested before and you're
doing a call or meeting like this if
your video is off human nature one third
of audience always multitasking we all
sing the smart I can listen to you I
also can do something else when you take
on the video everything is changed you
know people is more engaged easy to
build a trust that's why a video is a
future of communication video is a new
voice can you talk about the three
features that you are most excited to
build out right now so meaning the
feature not already in the roadmap
office already available in the product
it's a great question um both can I do
one or two of both number one feature I
like is what your backlog you know cause
quite often I talk with the customers I
I cannot be there fiscally but the five
minutes before the meeting I use a
customer's you know the headquarter
office or maybe their logo like I'm
using the GSP campus as my watch it back
on I feel I'm 0 already watching that's
number one feature a number two feature
for Troy is like some you know
some consumer features like a car
chopper your appearance a lot of cool
features and we are going to double down
on that however I think there are some
very cool features in the pipeline
I'm not seeing they're gonna be ready
soon but might it take many years effort
we got to partner with others like
real-time language translation you know
today you look at it this the the the
worldwide the problem is quite often
just a quarter
you know misunderstanding need to not
speak a similar language the language
barrier imagine a world where they can
use a zoo and you speaker you know see
English I wound understand Japanese a
Mandan rate with a our theaters
artificial intelligence with real-time
regular transition word is going to be a
much better place and some other
features are also in a little map right
I wonder sick hands with you Jennifer
but you cannot feel like that right in
the future with AI sensor technology I
think a lot of a cool features will be
added in the zoo or community ah
our goal is to build a solution like a
zoom to deliver a better experience than
face-to-face meeting um first of all I
can't wait for sanitized handshaking
that sounds like a perfect future um
people report being fatigued after
spending long hours on zoo I'm sure
you've experienced that why do you think
that is and how do you think we should
address it I screwed a question for the
first cell rigs I already found that as
well I can't hear you I think that in
April the world's the pig base I had a
total 19 zoo meetings and to be honest
with you I'm tired of with meetings
sometimes the reason why is because you
you feel like the first step for the
first several days you like that
experience but you always talk to people
talk to people you feel like you speak
negative but competitive fist to fist
meeting like a physical gathering is
totally totally different experience you
know the more meeting like this you more
feel like you are you truly
miss the real fist facility that's one
of the reasons
another reason is is because you always
you know because you work from home you
tend to have more meetings quite often
you have a back-to-back meetings and you
even do not have a time to stretch
yourself right and also you might have a
mental problem that's another reason for
the fatigue so for now I had no idea how
to fix that the only way is to make sure
folks on the in a wire wrist so I have a
vaccine technology and the air-vent I'm
back into the whole place to work okay
good good to know everyone on doom right
now 270 of them we can start working on
that I teach a class called humor
serious business and and we are on zoom'
for six hours on Tuesdays from three to
six and six to nine and so some of the
students encouraged us to you know
really enjoy the opportunity to think
about you know spicing things up a
little bit so for example they've
considered zooming and goats llamas this
is Jensen right here Erik with her goat
and the goat made guests expect guest
visits to our class what is the most
sort of interesting zoom either prank or
use of zoom that you've experienced in
the last couple months I think you know
two things and beg your first question
about if I take question I forgot to
mention that so yeah we also have a
daily sing up a meeting and we found
when things before we ended the meeting
we pick up one person to share a happy
story and about you know any happy story
I try to fix that phone so back to this
question I think there's so many new use
cases over the past the cervix I never
thought about that like a happy hour you
know on a wedding ceremony and you know
the health care and you know and Hannah
Madison well of the use of uses I feel
very interesting
we're problem is you know you can you
know the Xoom marriage is legal in New
York so and that's pretty interesting
and also that's probably the most
interesting use cases how you going to
resume wedding Eric I go to some
pictures but I do not join any live zoom
wedding ceremony okay are you are you
willing to be on the record that if any
Stanford GSB student has a zoom wedding
in the next month and they invite you
you might zoom bomb in or visit I'm a
committed now soon started as an
enterprise product um what do you think
is the long-term use case for these
social interactions so for example do
you want to be a facebook or and and
relatedly how do you think of your
competition moving forward
so our accommodated being a is still to
serve large enterprise and business
customers let's still our bread and
butter so I think after pandemic crisis
know we still wanted to relentlessly
focus on that but doing this pandemic a
crisis you know our number one goal is
to help the world to show our corporate
social responsibility that's why we do
all we can and no cost to embrace every
new use cases I do not think we will
compete against the Facebook and it's
totally different in the business I
think that in the future we should
believe video and voice those who are
tuned to be converged into one service
so meaning of your a lot of enterprise
customers their base full insisting you
know will be converged if it's a video
conferencing will be the same system
huge opportunity so we're going to work
on that and better the consumer use
cases we're also thinking very hard you
know how to add some nickel you know
some uni you know fun elements into that
like you know whom I joined your GSP you
know wedding ceremony ideally I wish the
beauty a button I hate send you a gift I
one click you know senator KP to Tarsus
others make it easier more like the not
only of
a video collaboration more like a
powerful and also hype others the even
can build a penis upon our platform so
the platform play is going to play a
bigger role for our future consumer
strategy I love the fact that your
Linkedin tagline says delivering
happiness to our users your happiness is
my happiness but you can tell that um
that where your mind is going is highly
aligned with with that um can you talk
about the aspects of how people are
working using zoom and other online
tools that you find to be problematic
and how you hope to resolve through
product innovation some of those more
problematic challenges I think that you
know different product you know had a
definite challenges you know when in
e-commerce resume and our in a goal the
philosophy when we started is to build
the most frictionless clapping Sprint's
focus on ease of use you know let me
just one click to join rather than two
clicks and do all we can because very
very easy that's how we go however the
challenge you know comes from you know
potential privacy issue or maybe
security I keep my exam where to fix
that used to be like two months back if
you have joined us zoom meeting the zoom
meeting ID it's gonna be you know
displayed in on the zoom a wheelie
window because easy for others to know
that immediately to join however you
know there's a problem is if I now as
some people are so excited it shared the
screen to the social media if your
meeting has no password guess what we
can zoom bombing into haamiti right it's
kind of a usability and privacy is
always you need to you know have a trade
off you know our channel if I now you
know the challenge before was focus on
usability
now I realize no we gotta focus on
privacy and a security right this is our
challenge
overall I think if you really want to
focus on the ease of use you can't have
a trade off I think almost every you
know a building services know they are
facing this kind of a challenge
specifically we're good a service for
enterprise customer you do not see any
other
companies in history a beautiful
enterprise brainy's over the night you
need a service so many first-time
consumer consumers like its it's totally
in I expected that's a challenge also do
you feel like that was a miss like
allowed me the security concerns and the
zoom bombing do you view that as kind of
a natural trade-off or do you do you
kind of view that as a miss or like I
wish I could have you know seen that
coming earlier on and tackled it how do
you view that screw the question it's
not a natural trade-off you know so when
we talk with like a British enterprise
customers normally there's Pusey right
and meaning you know our team working
together with the enterprise team we
have all you know cancel for security
features Beauty no Enterprise IT we will
decide which one to enable which when to
disable and if they have official
onboarding process in the their users
and they started using so that's
normally for enterprise customer to
become our customer however better
consumers you know if on the first day
you know this app account and started
using zoom there's no sort of onboarding
process I think we need to change our
business practice not only do we offer
service to customers but also play a low
of IT meaning we should only when
enforced those security features like we
should enforce password enforce waiting
room and remind you of how to lock the
meetings you know make it make the
first-time users easily to access all
those security features looking back I
think we should have done a better job
right and to serve those first-time
users those consumers um can you talk
about the technologies like zoom
widening inequalities for example
students without internet access can't
take online classes right now is that
something that you're thinking about and
planning to address as zoom becomes a
larger and more impactful organization
or how do you think about that that's a
great question so you know
back to internet way so you know a lot
of people you know take it for granted
it's not everyone has that internet
access that's not a case even you know
for users here sometimes you know
inequality
you know it's become a social problem my
internet access right how to have all
those families right to all we kind of
have them you know price even for some
penis customers right you know internet
you know sometimes you know the quality
not a good this market a can order the
innovation right we need to focus on
both side well it's a social problem you
know we should know to always kind of
help another one is about a technology
problem we need to keep working hard to
improve the product and experience um
love to talk about education for a
second um you have single-handedly
changed completely in my life not to
mention every other faculty and student
member of Stanford and broader can you
talk a little bit about your view on
education particularly in the u.s. some
upsides and downsides of a zoom enabled
education system yeah if you talk about
a higher let's table that k-12 schools I
think US has the best high head
assisting know better than any other
countries are far far ahead and others
reason why because the structure
innovation and the system and very
healthy ecosystem you take a Stanford
for example every time I wizard a
Stanford after I came back I was a full
of energy I can recharge myself you see
that you know over the culture for those
grid you know the universities however
Apple said is how to kind of happen more
students the North Area right they can
you kind of for join your class right
and how to lever the technology right
like some students probably in in
Pittsburgh or Phoenix right you know
they can join online class by some
people the register physically
physically clear and how to kind of
elaborate in technology to share the
experience you know to have more
students who may not have you know I
think you know the time or resources in
to join this kind of
class I think that's a way another thing
is how to make sure and in the future
you know after the financial crisis it
gives some students more flexibility
even if the journal say the registers at
Stanford right sometimes they might want
to travel for for a one week two month
this you can join the enjoy the class
right because this pandemic rice is
completely chin in a way for us to learn
to live and work absolutely
are they you downsize is you think about
you know like first you know you you
know you being a Stanford alumni kind of
putting yourself back back here and you
know we've got you know our 250 students
they're all gonna graduate in a week I
guess thinking about it from that
perspective are there any downsides to
this more zoom enabled education system
I don't think experience like a zoom can
replace that experience it's more of a
complementary to what we used to be like
you know physical gazing in the campus i
excusing by and large i think this is a
campus you know centric education
student mainstream because you or have
wonderful campus you can bond together
with your classmate and those kind of
facebook gasoline and you know kind of
what I think I learn together that
experience cannot be replaced you know
otherwise I'd remember that
why was that a GSB input on a six I
think the reason why I really like
because I'm leaving the campus I really
miss that at high and the day when I
left I was sort of like wow I just
realized how great energy Springs worse
I think it spent more time in a campus
and every year also coming back didn't
always go online I said all and just you
know I sing a small portion of that
experience
as a kind of love letter so to speak to
these students who are graduating in a
week what would you say are your top two
or three features that you would like to
build out if you just think of education
you know grad school at Stanford as a as
a vertical and you're gonna go deep into
that vertical what would be the top two
or three features that you would like to
build out I think the one feature is
more like we all have a software like a
brick out of room I I think how to
improve that experience you know like
see like a brick or room normally
managed by the host I think it's one
student another student you know we they
want to have their own breakout session
right they can't lose to I want to learn
you know from each other right learn
this subject this feature you know I
think this should be added in another
feature is more like to improve our
meeting transmission feature you know
sometimes you know I miss the class or
maybe during the class between some
zeroes which have a really kind meeting
transcription by from a speech-to-text
and that's a second feature sort of is
more like you also are doing that as
well more like a summary if I miss the
class and I needed to play back for you
know 45 minutes I did it zoom can
leverage AI technology to generally like
a five minute summary
and with that I seen probably five
minutes I'm not saying we care but at
least the give our students are a amuri
about the topic of this class credit I'm
gonna ask a couple questions we have
like about eight more minutes and then
I'll open it up to some student
questions as well um a few personal
questions so we live in such a surreal
time right now certainly you could ever
imagine that this idea of this you know
your relationship with your girlfriend
would lead into this remarkable moment
of time what has surprised you the most
about your life right now your
personally we
yeah I also along with others always
think about working from home and I
think that should be great experience I
think I'm completely wrong to always
working from home is pretty tough it's
not an easy I think that's very
surprised and and a lot of people
mention that you you become busier and
we also did a survey you know more
employees might have a mental problems I
think you know we got into a thing about
that you know you cannot have always
think about working from home go to
Singapore maybe go back office well make
a comeback at home gotta be how to hire
break so that's the most surprised to
experience how what has changed in your
life in the last couple of months and
what has stayed the same
what had changed I realized you know to
hang out with the friends and with
colleagues with the alligators is very
very important and that's one thing I am
miss the most cause quite often I have a
lunch or dinner with some customers with
Odyssey use I want to learn from and
it's really hard I really miss that
experience what I started changed is you
know I keep using zoom
I still enjoy using that and yeah that's
yeah it's pretty much most of
reminiscing yeah what keeps you up at
night
and what is the first thing you think of
in the morning the first thing why I
think in the morning is about how to
make sure our employees they still feel
happy and this is the number one thing I
also included myself cuz we always told
our employees we wake up the first
question you should ask about yourself
do you feel happy or not if you do feel
happy you know used to be pleased to
come to office to work if you do not
feel happy you can stay at home to
figure out a root cause so for me I'll
see you my number and job is to make
sure our employee happy doing this
pandemic crisis you know some employee
you know the family member or maybe God
you know impacted and you know I think a
lot you think about a lot how to make
sure all five employee happy um a lot of
our research shows that the meaning of
happiness shifts over the life course
that it moves from excitement to conquer
in the world to balance to impact and
then to sort of peacefulness or meaning
in savoring what would you say when you
say you want your employees to be happy
and that's what you wake up with how are
you defining happiness yes it's great a
great question so I and maybe a little
bit of story actually it's been boils
down to the purpose of life you know I
my mood is sitting a while II I worked
so hard I habitus web as to become
public company I remember on the day
winds web as many public I suddenly got
lost
cuz I always had a question for the
purpose of life I'm suddenly I'm told to
be a further word um I do not know the
purpose of life but later on realized
the purpose of life is about a happiness
and the sustainable happiness comes from
making others happy as long as everyday
you think about how to make others happy
you'll be happy you'll be happier and
those that happiness is very sustainable
that was a really good really good
answer Eric um you must have done a lot
of work around behavioral psychology and
can you talk a little bit about another
personal question you applied nine times
to get your visa to the United States
why did you keep applying did you ever
consider giving up so that's good
practice you know for for me to start a
company in the future right so the
reason why is I like sports you know
like watching the soccer game or
possible game I'm a huge fan of NBA when
you put his spots he never wanted to
give up and I never wanted to give up
when I try to apply a visa I told myself
unless they to me that they rejected me
forever
otherwise I will keep trying the good
news I tried eight eight times the next
attempt I was successful by the way it's
pretty good already prepared about
twenty times so are to beat him I go so
that's good I'm gonna go twenty times a
is a win that's fantastic um a couple of
other questions and then all I'll bring
in some student questions as well what
do you want your legacy to be somebody
in the future we need why done a book a
story I bought you know pandemic you
know crises cover the nineteen story I
hope they remember there's a company
called zoom did I write a thing for the
word to helping people stay connected
great and I'm gonna end my questions
with some lightning round questions
there do you remember these from like
view from the top or other things these
are fast rapid-fire questions you can't
think you just have to answer ok you
ready yes I'm ready
alright koopa or Arbuckle Koopa fun zoom
background or planes OOP resume
background phone zoom back rock ideal
number of people and a breakout room
break on a ruler alright ideal number of
people on a breakout room I know it's
not a yes or no by people by favorite
app of choice choice choice yeah what's
your favorite app sous-sous Zuckerberg
or Bezos both best wait as a boy zoom
fatigue gold police spots don't assume
favorite startup idea and you recently
heard of sale sale goose or give keema
gifts on zoom' platform and favorite GSB
memory everything Oh guys I would really
encourage you all to get married this
month on zoom' Erickson get you a gift
okay no no one in this month's anytime
I'm a huge pound but just like any night
what what about remarriages I'm happily
married right now but I am willing to
explore a divorce in a remarriage if
that offer is open that's good idea I
will follow you as well alright guys
this has been a really productive
business and society lecture all right
I'm gonna bring in a few student
questions that are coming live from our
non chat situation but they apply a lot
more to some of the the Kovach kind of
experiences that we found so some
students would like to ask you can zoom
be a great leveler that
minces east coast people that the west
coast offices are equivalent to being
there in New York or Boston what zoom
features would help with that
yeah that's complications I think a
technology like a zoom is not ready for
that
and we needed to keep working harder and
to added some features to make sure
actually there's no distance we use the
zoom for now you feel like a zoom is
still what you experience as a mission
in earlier our goais they live a much
better experience that fits to this
meeting they can't reach that ago I
think we can achieve that again
you mentioned there's a lot of interest
around this idea of what what really is
human interaction in in our AI class we
teach a classical designing AI for human
wellbeing and it goes into this idea
like what what does it really mean to be
human one of the students asked you you
mentioned wanting zoom to be better as a
you know to enable these in-person human
interactions is there anything that you
think is unique to in-person
interactions that just can't be replaced
I think I believe everything can be
replaced just a be patient need like a
Wang's MOC meet Jennifer you are you
know drinking a coffee right it's in the
future one click we can leverage
technology to digitize the smell I can
enjoy the smell here when you're doing a
coffee all those technologies will be
ready in the future everything can be
replaced interesting we're gonna have to
talk about that later
I don't know if I agree with you but
it's a it's a very provocative question
um have you examined neuroscience
research related to virtual connection
and if so what have you learned
I think of what your connection is a
woman way to help you connect with as
many people as possible that's
abundantly there's no any other ways and
with the technology I think
the experience will be very
unprecedented meaning a lot of thing you
sing about it before you know like all
those the movies like you know one click
you can feel like you're sitting
together with somewhere in the same
physical office and we totally different
background you can make a friendship and
very quickly you know time in a manner I
think a lot of thing can be achieved
with what you what you experience um how
do you think the end of the quarantine
or or this this next phase we're able to
kind of reintegrate will effect the use
of zoom so how will zoom maintain its
advantage in the future to stays or at
top of mind and customers favorites so
for sure you know when we go back office
after this pandemic crisis the way for
us to use the zoom also is different
than the way we use resume before
because zoom will be used for business
communications or maybe on in class or
telemedicine before for now I think a
lot of new use cases experienced over
the positive Sarah mosque will stay
that's that's for sure another thing is
people were realized
work from home might be okay that's why
in the future a lot of hybrid working
environment maybe one week working from
home while making the office and for
online class might be the same how do
you see foresee growth through
acquisition in the near future for zoom
to drive innovation using AI so there's
interest in understanding your vision
for growth through acquisition that's
great a question so and we are also you
know beefing up our corporate BDT and
we're we're asking with this question
has any good ideas please let me know
the questions awesome because organic a
grows can really help you to grow to a
level where you suddenly you feel like
your organic growth cannot be so
right that's why we just acquired our
first acquisition the KB's is a new
york-based company I think you know to
help us like those technology the new
market opportunities in a winner to be
you know open-minded I to look at are
there any other companies or technology
to help us all right
you guys heard that you're supposed to
zoom Eric if you have ideas there with
so many video products FaceTime blue
jeans Google Sky WebEx that set our
teams out there before zoom with similar
technology can you talk about two
ingredients that made you succeed in
that crowded space I know we talked
about the core being loved
the core being customer and customer
centricity the ability to have trust and
an ability to be agile but are there any
other features that you think made it so
that zoom became such a leader I think
first of all the first ingredient is
don't look at competitors if you look at
a competitor's I even do not dare to
start assume because there's so many
solution the orders they're already
always focus on your customers on your
users don't focus on competitors that's
number one as number two is about your
architecture make sure your architecture
very scalable sustainable secure
otherwise maneuver there is suddenly
like this pandemic crisis the one for
the key reasons why some of the
competitors their solutions not a
scalable because architecture from our
perspective we do not need to change our
architecture those security security and
the performance already good compared to
any other competitors great your parents
were both mining engineers and mining is
an industry that's certainly evolved and
has been forced to change dramatically
is there anything you've learned with
observing your parents and how that
industry changed that you can apply
to your own business and more broadly
the videoconferencing space yes sorry my
parents is a background in their
theology
you know the engineers know the mining I
think that oh okay yes I will I will
correct the students they clearly do not
do their homework close their homework
right I think it s expected the social
media news reporter sometimes the story
may not be right but anyway I think I
don't think I you know because of their
you know the big one for sure you know I
went into the the college with that
background I is you know I did not go to
the top-tier universities just and you
know you know I'm like you know manning
audiology related you know the the
University of the Carter that's probably
the biggest inference however I did
learn you know one thing for my you know
my father is you know how to work stayed
humble no matter what do you do what is
your favorite food that your mom makes
you or made you for lunch I can tell you
I working for my home the wedding I
really like like a most is and every
morning my mom you know gave me a you
know kind of cook the breakfast and also
lunch and dinner is my wife and the
momma together anything cooked by my mom
I really enjoy that I really enjoy that
because you sort of you know give you a
lot of expression my age like you know
let it remind me of I was a kid my mom
cooked for me for now and I'm already
our age 50 everything why eat the food
at cooking my mom I have full of
gratitude oh that's adorable
not only that but your parents are
impressive for different reasons
another question that's more
hard-hitting than favorite food that
your mom made um one of our students
wants to know do you could a could a I
help participants understand micro cues
and micro facial expressions I'm not
sure if that was a I
but can you talk a little bit about
understanding people's micro cues or
micro facial expressions so how might
you think about enhancing human
connections thrill zoom by these kind of
more visual cues yeah so great a great
question for now the technology is not
already but it would be essentially
personal AI
like hey be nice treat a topic in a way
like a face detection you know can tell
me hey slow down in the audience I mean
honest and I think the you know AI and a
video technology and a face detection
all those technologies will achieve that
ago um what okay I want to know what is
what are two or three questions or
challenges that you want to toss out to
our students we've got two hundred and
seventy students online ish and you're
you know a huge celebrity they are so
excited to you know basically absorb
everything you're saying what would be
two or three challenges or questions you
like to pose them
I think the first one is make sure you
know the purpose of life that's number
one number two think about what you can
do differently to the world or I know as
to what you can do to contribute back to
GSB oh that's fantastic
so we're so incredibly thankful for what
you've given back to us in so many ways
right
not just today and your time with us
today in such an important class that um
that Brian and the team actually create
out of nothing and just the invention of
this class is a great testament to not
just the contribution of you being here
but also the contribution of zoom so
we're so incredibly grateful for what
you've been able to do and it's a it's a
great sort of inspiration
for for others as well I'd like to end
on a final note which is a reminder to
everyone to build technologies based on
love and to know the purpose of life
before you leave you've got one more
week
so Eric's ready to help you out and and
think about what you can do that's
that's bigger than yourself thank you so
much Eric we really really appreciate
your time
Brian thank you so much for anything
this to happen thank you both it was a
really great conversation I was happy to
be able to hear it and they're gonna add
my thanks to Jennifer as Eric it's been
great to have you here and thanks for
the technology we've used it quite a bit
on here recently of the GSB and it's
great to have you here to talk about it
and I will echo what Jennifer said to
the students you have one week to
discover the meaning of life enjoy so
don't waste it what's the time
so again Eric thank you so much and I
hope you all I hope you had a great time
I'm sure the students learned a lot and
enjoy the rest of your day
[Music]